if you play it right for yourself it
could be the most remarkable thing but
as a collective these very early days
are super important this is inevitable
at scale this is watching this makes me
laugh because this is exactly what the
rooms look and this is actually way more
this is more even though it's just these
days for me a small group you know this
is way more faces than the ones that I
saw in the tech space and a lot of these
faces went on to become the founders of
uber and succs
and the founders of Instagram and things
that nature so couple things number one
you got your perspective
[Music]
in 2006 and seven when I went to South
by Southwest people were there to be
part of tech for the sake of tech to
change the world the the the aspirations
and the ideology were remarkable the far
majority of this room today 20 18 right
here together is in it for it they've
been in it they're not flying in from
Wall Street or Silicon Valley there's
people in here there's people in here
but the majority of this room is in it
now this is super important as I hear
that wonderful thank you and I get it
and I respect that
this is a very important conversation
I'll tell you why the OGIS in this room
that have been through it that been you
know it's funny I was spending some time
and looking at an article being rated
and I was telling some of the people on
my team who don't even hear this story
the amount of times the ABC came to wine
library because I was navigating and
doing things early that nobody ever did
before and when your biggest you get
picked on because you can pay the fine
don't get it twisted it's very simple
it's called winners tax they don't tell
you that a b-school but that's what it
is I'll say it this way it's unfortunate
for me unlike when I got into tech or
many other things I've done in my life
because of the profiles my business
career it's harder for me to kind of go
into new spaces and do what I naturally
want to do to be very frank I I don't
know if I've ever felt the combination
of of gratitude and feeling humble and
at the same token a sense of
responsibility of giving this talk today
because much like the way I entered into
the tech space sort of wide space for
other things that I've done I just want
to learn right there's a lot you know
I'm doing a lot of listening the reason
I teamed up with Josh ROM and the rest
of Green Street is I didn't want to come
into this space and think that I knew
everything or things that nature I want
to take it nice and slow and pay
attention being underestimated and
misunderstood is a massive business
advantage there's a lot of people in
this room that are so desperate for
acceptance of like this is real and
all these kind of things like this is
gonna be in it spending so much time
trying to convince somebody of the
legitimacy or the seniority or the
sophistication of the space without
realizing that they should be spending
100% of their time on the end consumer
and building their advantage their
leverage and preference of the majority
of the people in this room would
actually be for people coming into the
space to dramatically slow down not
speed up for all the good that dollars
and all these other things come out the
more time that you have planting your
flag and establishing your brand and
building a relationship with the end
consumer the more leverage you have
trying to convince people that are no
people is a waste of time and I think
that's just something some of you need
to hear because that no person for a lot
of you is your [ __ ] mom that no
person is that your brother that you
respect or your homie or your silic so
just be very thoughtful of who you try
to convince this is real because I think
that's a lot of wasted energy in early
times number two you need to be
thoughtful of all the new people that
are coming in if you play it right for
yourself it can be the most remarkable
thing but as a collective these very
early days are super important this is
inevitable at scale this is watching
this makes me laugh because this is
exactly what the rooms look and this is
actually way more this is more even
though it's just these days for me a
small room you know this is way more
faces than the ones that I saw in the
tech space and a lot of these faces went
on to become the founders of uber and
sucks and the founders of Instagram and
things that nature so couple things
number one if you are fortunate enough
to be smart enough and that's the only
word I can think of if you are fortunate
enough to be smart enough to be in this
[ __ ] room right now please do not do
what so many of my homies from tech in
2006 7 & 8 to to me which is reminisce
and are sad that they did not take full
advantage of their pole position and
where the world was going the biggest
mistake that so many of you will do
today is not network with other people
at this place what I really am
passionate about is for people in this
room to understand how many
options we do have if you're in this
space even if you're a brand or if
you're a grower your permission to be
the media company of this space is there
aka every [ __ ] person this room needs
to start thinking about their podcast
yesterday
every single person this room needs to
be thinking about writing a white paper
and putting it on LinkedIn yesterday
everybody here has to shift from crying
and that's what a lot of you are doing
Wow
Instagram and Facebook and Google aren't
taking my money nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your tears stop crying about what
you can't do and start figuring out what
you can do you can be dominating
Instagram spend the [ __ ] 900 hours
building out an influencer network so
that can [ __ ] do posts and give you
cosines you could you could start a
YouTube vlog and document the journey of
building your business in a space along
the way I wish I could watch suckss
[ __ ] blog and how he built Facebook
you know if he was doing this ten years
ago god forbid a que God willing your
company explodes that vlog of how you
made it is gonna be watched for the next
50 [ __ ] years in perpetuity you can
do a ton of [ __ ] but we have to shift
our marketing mindset in this space from
being advertisers to being media
companies we have to produce content you
have to produce content so I implore you
to take advantage of this remarkable
moment in your industry where it's not a
baby but it hasn't even started and I
highly recommend you understand how
early platforms an industry start the
ROI is in the [ __ ] people the ROI is
in the [ __ ] people I promise you
right now everybody is watching how
you're navigating right now everybody is
watching and there's a lot of you and
I'm [ __ ] was in the hall for four
minutes there's a lot of you
unfortunately getting seduced by the
short term ROI and finances in the
system and everybody knows it and you
will lose three of you will get through
and make that trade that's fine we'll
never see you again but most of you will
have a scarlet letter for trying to take
from it instead of giving to it look if
you make a podcast
called 43 year old mom that's literally
the name of it and you're targeting
housewives and high-net-worth
individuals who are gonna be in the
edible space because that's who you're
targeting you've got to really just go
after your con your target audience with
content that they'll consume that's
always been the case but the reason I
said 1 2 & 3 is patience is because
that's what it's gonna take
there's still a [ __ ] massive stigma
go [ __ ] read the first 15 years of
prohibition you know what the biggest
scariest things in the world are having
too little and having too much when
you're poor is [ __ ] on welfare you
don't think the trust fund baby who's
got a hundred mils got it bad you think
that's the greatest well you don't
realize that kid is always gonna be told
that he never made it and he's got a
drug problem and [ __ ] up and I'm meds
and at the psychiatrist cuz his game is
broken before he even started the bottom
line is my dear everybody's got [ __ ]
problems too because when it's yours
it's yours and so I navigate happy
because I'm just grateful for what I
have and other people have more other
people have less when I had a whole lot
less I was happy with the [ __ ] I had and
I just every day recognize that if I'm
in my own head and realize that
everybody's got their own [ __ ] too then
I don't spend time complaining and
dwelling I spend time on doing this is
forever you have made a decision to be
an industry that will be over regulated
for the rest of your life I promise you
that
and that's super okay either the first
20 years of my business life in a super
regulated business but it still sucks
compared to not regulated businesses
like I don't know that's to tell you and
so much like the admiration I have for
Travis I could have never built
uber because Travis had a DNA that was
good at fighting City Hall I'm scared of
City Hall
that's just my DNA so I think everybody
here has to make a decision for them if
they have the must you know the muscles
memory and the stomach to deal with the
ebbs and flows of things the toughest
thing and anybody will know this the
number one toughest thing to me in life
is not having little cuz you don't know
it's having little getting something
getting a lot and then losing it
people going backwards just struggle and
I think the toughest thing in a
regulated business is cool they open up
Illinois a couple people here to have
Chicago routes or they move they go and
they crush it they saw what happened in
Cali they want to deal in like they
[ __ ] kill it and for some reason
seven years later they reregulate it and
it's gone tough that is what you're
signing up for and I think the better
kind of like nobody gives a [ __ ] about
your feelings right the the quicker you
understand this is going to be regulated
in perpetuity then you can start really
starting to think about how you navigate
and how you go about it so I wish you
guys the best I'm so grateful that I was
able to give this talk at this time it
means a lot to me I'm super excited to
get to know the majority of you over the
next two or three decades and I wish you
great health and great success thank you
so much
[Applause]
everybody thank you guys
[Music]